Do you need grammar to speak?
Well, the quick answer is no.
In my opinion, I tend
to agree with Stephen
Krashen that
grammar can be a hindrance,
it can be a help.
It can explain things to us.
It can explain things that we have
already experienced in the language.
It can show us examples of different
patterns that we can then use.
However, if we try to
remember the grammar, if we
try to second-guess ourselves,
then grammar becomes what Stephen
Krashen calls the "affective filter."
It's something that emotionally we
start to doubt whether what we would
normally retrieve as easy to use, or
patterns that we're comfortable using.
And we do it on the fly
while we're speaking.
And now we start to say, well, "Is
this correct?" and we want to pass it
through this filter of grammar.
"Is this correct?"
And basically that inhibits
us in our speaking.
It's like the proverbial centipede,
you know, a hundred feet.
If it has to think about which
foot to put forward, the left
foot or the right foot, pretty
soon the centipede can't walk.
So grammar has its role.
Some people actually like
grammar, so that's fine.
But if the goal is to speak well, some
people think you need to focus on grammar
in order to speak well. I don't think so!
It gets back to the example
of the chess player.
Someone who knows the rules is
no match for someone who has
vast experience playing chess.
So the question then is, first of
all, what is meant by speaking?
What do we... what happens when
we speak? Before getting into the
question of what "speaking well" means,
let's just consider what speaking entails.
Speaking entails, as I mentioned in my
last video, speaking entails planning.
We actually have to plan the
utterance, what we're going to say.
And planning it draws on our memory.
And planning and memory come from the
same part of our brain, and when we
speak, apparently, we begin by grabbing
easy to use words or structures
that we're very comfortable with.
This is if we're speaking in a foreign
language; I presume maybe in our own
languages we use those things that
we're comfortable starting with.
That gives us time to plan the next
thing we're going to say. And we also
reuse structures that we're comfortable
using, that have worked for us before.
So there are three elements.
One is easy to use items.
The second is planned reuse, but the third
one is, suppressing things that don't fit.
So that can be words that sound similar,
but they're not appropriate words that
have a similar meaning, but are not
exactly what we want in this context.
Or it could be patterns
from our own language.
So I've noticed that Swedish people
typically will say "It is many trees
in the forest" instead of "There are,"
because that's the pattern in Swedish.
German people will say, "I have been
living in the United States since many
years," but in fact it's "for many years."
Because in German, that's the pattern.
So when we're speaking, we need
to pull from our memory words that
we are very comfortable using, the
easy to use things to get started.
We then reuse structures that worked
before, but we suppress words or
patterns that don't work. And that
apparently when they measure what
happens in the brain, that's what we do.
So obviously we need a vast repertoire of
We need a lot of memory experience,
words, patterns that work in the language.
So that's when we speak.
What do we mean by speaking?
Well at LingQ, I used to
tutor English 15 years ago.
And at that time we kept statistics.
We had sort of types of errors that people
made. Because at that time, I thought it
would be useful to point out to a learner,
"You had X percent was singular/
plural, X percent was wrong tense,
X percent was something else."
And for each language,
we had these categories.
Well, overwhelmingly—and I even
did correct some people in French—
overwhelmingly, the biggest
problem was incorrect word usage.
In other words, it wasn't so much
that it was grammatical mistakes,
it was that the words they used
together are words that normally in
English we wouldn't use together.
And after all, when we say "speak
well," we're not talking about some
theoretical, logical way that
the language should be used.
Many of those sort of structures in other
languages that interfere with us when
we're speaking a new language,
they're logically fine in their language:
double negatives, or "it is
many trees in the forest."
It's fine logically, but that's
just not how the language is used.
So the most common type of error is
using words that don't belong together.
There is a term, "colocation,"
which talks about words that
are normally found together.
There are so many potential colocations.
I don't think it's worthwhile
studying a list of colocations.
It's a matter more of being exposed to so
much of the language that you naturally
feel that certain words belong together.
Another aspect of speaking well,
and as I say, I'm going to leave
pronunciation out of the equation.
I might do a separate
video on pronunciation.
I think you can speak the
language very well and have
an obvious accent.
The two issues are different.
But if we say "speaking well,"
what do we mean by speaking well?
We mean using words with precision.
So if we talk about "language acquisition"
and we have the verb "acquire."
Now there are many similar words.
I mean, there is the word "get,"
which is a very general and
therefore not a very precise word.
There is the word "obtain."
But we "obtain satisfaction."
We "acquire a language."
We "get fed up."
In other words, there are so many examples
of how the accurate way to use a given
word and one that is natural. Because our
goal is to be natural in the language.
Now, what is natural in Quebec
may not be natural in France, in
so far as French is concerned.
What is natural in Scotland may not
be natural in Australia. But there
is a natural form of the language.
That is valuable to us because those are
the people we want to communicate with.
And in order to become a good speaker, and
therefore to speak naturally and to speak
well, you have to have a large vocabulary.
You have to be able to use words
precisely, and you have to be able to
use words that naturally belong together.
And even if you create
a sentence which is
logical grammatically, but
the wrong words are used,
I don't consider that speaking well.
So the grammar, these rules and
reading up on the rules, there's
nothing wrong with doing that.
It's possible that if you read a grammar
book, and I would recommend reading a
grammar book in the target language, and
if this grammar book has lots of examples,
that can help provide you with this
inventory of phrasing that you can draw on
when you're planning your utterance. But
ultimately you have to develop a natural
reflex so that when you go through this
process of planning your utterance, that
you have a natural ability to bring out
easy to use words, structures that work, and
you suppress those things that don't work.
So you won't be surprised to hear that
I think that input is the key
to speaking well. Bbut input and
output are intricately connected.
So just as when we speak, we're
drawing from our memory and we're
planning what to say and we're trying
to anticipate what we're going to
use. When we are listening or reading,
we are also active.
We are also anticipating
what's going to come at us.
That has been proven in
the studies they do, the ERP
studies of the brain and so forth.
So the two activities are interrelated,
but it still boils down to spending
enough time reading and listening
that you develop this ability
to produce the language. And
reading and listening
are a little different.
First of all, when you are speaking,
of course you're practicing speaking,
of course you are listening to what
the other person has to say, and of
course, that's a valuable thing to do.
And as you develop a stronger and
stronger base in the language, you
want to speak as much as you can, as
often as you can without worrying
about how you do, because you will
gradually improve if you keep speaking.
However, when it comes to the input
activities, reading and listening
are a little different. Listening,
and especially if you're listening to
something that grabs you, like an audio
book, a story that creates sort of an
emotional connection to the language.
It can also happen in reading, but
reading is a little bit different.
There's the sound of the language.
Again, as we grow older, the different
parts of our brain apparently
become more and more interconnected.
The myelin coating speeds up the
connections with different parts
of the brain, and so your emotions,
your empathy, your feelings,
all of these become more closely connected
with the sort of purely, you know,
thinking or reasoning part of your brain.
And so when we are learning a language and
we want to acquire these words, then it's
important that we connect emotionally
with what we're listening to and reading.
That's why it's so important
to choose things of interest
to you to listen to or read.
It's also true, apparently,
that when we are reading,
in our brain, it's as if we
were speaking to ourselves.
So reading is also a form of
output, a form of speaking.
So that's just to say that all of
these activities are interconnected.
So even if you don't have the
opportunity to speak the language
where you're living, getting engaged
with input activities can help you
improve your ability to speak.
And it is certainly true that
in our own languages, the people
who speak the best are the people
who have read the most widely.
So reading is very important in order to
improve your ability, eventually, to speak.
Now, some of you may say, "Yeah,
but I... how can I listen when
I don't understand anything?
How can I read when I have so few words?"
So obviously you have to gradually
build up your ability to read.
I think the goal should be
to read a paper book. Again,
there's some research that
suggests that we learn better from
paper books than from digital
materials: tablets or or computer screens.
But you can't get to a paper book
until you have a sufficient vocabulary.
And of course, that's why we developed—
you're not surprised again to hear
me say, but that's why I developed—
LingQ. Because I had these books at
home in Spanish and German, full
of words that I didn't understand.
And so I couldn't enjoy reading them.
But I wanted to get to where I
can enjoy reading a paper book.
And that's why had LingQ. We
can start with "Mini Stories."
You can go through material
in sentence view. There's so many
different ways that you can gradually
build up, in a somewhat intensive way,
your ability to eventually read
extensively. And if you can eventually
read novels and serious books or books on
subject of interest to you, extensively.
Buy paper [books], always have a book with
you, and you read widely in the
language that you're learning.
You will become a good speaker of that
language and you won't need to remember,
or try to remember, rules of grammar in
order to speak well. Because you will
automatically, as you retrieve the words
you want to use and the structures you want
to use, and you suppress structures that
you don't want, or the words that you
don't want to use. You're going to become a
better and better speaker of the language.